greater
Saint Greta of the Blessed sailboat I
know she sounds kind of Irish I'm trying
to do a Swedish I don't know how to do I
don't know okay I'm not
I'll work on it we'll try it again next
time Saint Greta
was just arrested
she was arrested by law enforcement in
Germany
I would have expected that she would
have gone to Davos either to appear at
the world economic Forum or to protest
the world economic Forum even though the
world economic Forum loves Greta but
that didn't happen because she was
arrested in Germany
she was protesting the expansion of a
coal mine in Western Germany and
according to Reuters she was warned by
police that she would be removed by
force if she did not vacate the mine
site and what did Saint Greta do she did
not vacate the Mayan's site and so what
happened she was dragged off by police
marking I believe the first time that
Greta has ever been arrested
I assumed she would have been arrested
as a teenager for skipping school for
like 180 days in a row but no I don't
know maybe the laws are different over
there in Sweden in America I think that
would have happened truancy laws but
this apparently was the first time she
was arrested
and
what the libs have said now is it's time
for many more of us to stand up and risk
arrest for the sake of being a livable
planet that's right she stood up to
power except some video came out not
just of her arrest where they're
dragging her off but video of a little
bit before the arrest
when Greta is
paling around with the cops
and actually posing for photos with them
you see everybody Smiles giggling
taking some photos all these great uh
just laughing having a grant okay but
then photos come she's gonna strains at
her face a little bit
maybe the cops posing
and they're posing holding her arm and
her hand for the reporters
she's there looking defiant cops aren't
they're not actually arresting her
they're just posing and then they
finally walk with her in the position of
arresting her
some are suggesting that this was all a
stunt cooked up by Greta thunberg that
these weren't real police officers that
they were just men wearing costumes I
don't think that's true I bet I don't
know for sure but I bet those were real
cops
no no the explanation for this photo op
followed by a
fake arrest I guess a technically a real
arrest but then they released her
immediately they just checked her
identity and let her go and the whole
thing was just such a fraud
the real explanation is far darker than
Greta paid some actors Jesse smallett
Style the real explanation is that
they're all on the same side
Greta and the police are pretending that
they're on opposite sides and they're
fighting but they're not they're on the
same side this is why it's always such a
farce when Greta protests at things like
the world economic Forum or any other
liberal event says you're not going far
enough the libs love that the libs love
the the pressure from the left
to give them an opportunity to seize
even more control and pursue an even
more radical agenda than they were
already doing
gives them the excuse to say well we're
getting popular pressure from Saint Mary
to have the Blessed sailboat and so
we've we've got to do this sort of thing
you don't need a conspiracy theory for
that this is how the system works
there is the appearance of opposition
but
very often it's simply that it's a
facade and the people who appear to be
locked locking horns fighting to the
death they're really paddling around
they're really on the same team
you see this from the Republicans who
cheer on the globalists at Davos there's
a republican Congressman Maria Salazar
who showed up through the world economic
forum
not to defend American National
sovereignty not to say that we won't eat
the bugs and live in the pods give away
all our property to clash Bob no she
showed up there
to demand dignity
for illegal aliens in America
for the last third five years
the party has been able to do
overhaul of the immigration system
because not only we need those hands
like the Congress that like us a senator
was saying but we need to also give
dignity to those people who are in the
country and those are the people that I
represent we're talking about 13 15
million people who are most of them
Hispanics I would say 85 percent who
speak my language look like me and sound
like me that are contributing with the
economy of this country and they live in
the shadows so it's time to seal the
Border like she said put order let's see
who comes in and who doesn't and then
turn around and give dignity that
doesn't mean path to citizenship that
means to include them and make them
dignified members of our community thank
you
how does that not mean path to
citizenship in what in what way do the
illegal aliens in America lack dignity
that is not merely synonymous with
citizenship or a pathway to citizenship
in what way you're saying they're
contributing to the economy okay so
they're getting jobs it's not that
they're being kept out of getting jobs
like when the Irish came here and in New
York they put up signs Irish need not
apply because there was a prejudice
against the Irish that's not what's
happening Hispanics are getting a ton of
jobs in America that's why they keep
coming
is it they're not being allowed into
restaurants no they're being allowed
into any public accommodation they want
is it that they're not being addressed
by the political class no the political
class not only the Democrats who are
importing them by the millions every
year but the Republicans like Maria
Salazar they can't stop babbling about
the illegal aliens and how great they
are in fact Maria Salazar said that she
represents them
when did that happen
I maybe I'm a little bit thick maybe I'm
a little bit stupid it's been a while
since I took Civics I thought though
that the members of Congress represented
their constituents who voted for them
who voted in the elections who are
citizens who are members of that
political community
that by definition would exclude the
foreign Nationals who are illegally
residing in our country in contravention
of the most basic laws of our country
and what does she say she says I
represent them she does I'm sure she
does when these people tell you who they
are believe them says I represent the
illegals that's true
she doesn't represent you
she shows up to Davos she Pals around
with all the libs yeah she's got an R
next to her name maybe she votes the
right way look we have a thin majority
in the House of Representatives I'll
take what I can get
so that Republicans can maintain control
but you think she represents you you
crazy
she just told you she doesn't
she told you that she represents
foreigners
and she represents them
before she represents you if she
represents you at all she represents
them first and she goes to their parties
first and she speaks on their fancy
panels first and she she is she is dead
set on giving them dignity the world
economic forum is dead set on taking
away your dignity
and and the best you can say is we need
to give foreign criminals
more dignity more than we've already
given them which is quite a lot
[Music]
[Music]